at its peak the company was worth ten
billions and billion dollars ten billion
dollar valuation and so for my insider
perspective there was a moment in time
with the term unicorn happened out here
right everybody wanted to be involved in
the next unicorn right she benefited
heavily from the she had been around for
like eight years meandering with this
company ten years ten years and then the
unicorn bang happened and she was able
to jump on that bandwagon pretty much I
mean the the company was founded in late
2003 in that coin that term was coined
by venture capitalists in November 2013
and within a couple months she was able
to raise money and evaluation that
valued tharros at more than nine billion
dollars for a couple months in early
2014 their nose was actually the most
valuable private company in Silicon
Valley it was more valuable than uber
what it was killing me John it was more
valuable than Airbnb than crazy than
Spotify you're talking about companies
that actually have products that people
use every day